yeah many people don't have the luxury
to work inside in a cool environment
like construction workers and those who
are working on this fear they have to
get the work done i spoke to a worker on
a project in the northwest valley you
won't believe how many of these he's
drinking a day
i drink like probably
15 bottles a day besides his
construction tools mario lopez says
there is always a water bottle in his
hand every 30 minutes i drink one or two
the company he works for provides a
cooler full of water for their crew
still gotta you know get the job done
and with multiple breaks in the shade
he's able to get his work done he says
his work shift is now 6 a.m to 2 p.m
with noon being the toughest hour i got
like three or four chairs you know to
keep our cool but there's always danger
i spoke with eric bendela who is
currently studying the outside workforce
in the heat with desert research
institute we found that the most
affected population is those who has
five years or more working for the same
employee he also found that women
working outdoors were more susceptible
to heat related illnesses before this
study he was looking into the mortality
rate for southern nevada when it comes
to heat the number of cases of people
dying because of extreme heat increase
it for less than 10 when we start the
analysis to over 50. so no matter how
long you have lived in the desert you
should always take extra precautions
because you may never know how your body
could react
so if you find yourself working outdoors
mandala did say you should be drinking
about seven ounces of water every half
an hour and make sure to add some
electrolytes in there as well
reporting near the strip victoria zaha
live local now